here we go
buddy heels buddy hill oh
boy the kings come to motown and they
steal the game
they steal the game buddy hill
stuns the crowd here in detroit
back them up and send them home grant
napier
the sacramento kings have shocked the
detroit pistons
but he healed 35 points
and the game winner
wow
let's look at that sequence again yes
buddy gets the basketball
bobbles it a little bit doesn't lose his
poise puts it back down on the floor
reaches up that is a one
porter junior inbounds it to jokic
almost knocked away
they get the steal bars for the lead
couldn't punch it tipped up no
will it count buddy ball
call game run buddy run
oh sacramento with a tip and get out of
town
for the victory
man so many questions a wild
unfathomable inexplicable
sequence barnes
had it partially blocked but buddy
healed had his back all the way back
there
mark jones and counted doug who is he
mark jones paco my bad sent
him home buddy hill look at this
tip oh yo yeah that's right before the
lights went on
on the backboard by rule it's reviewed
but buddy's not sticking around doug the
defensive effort by harrison barnes not
giving an
inch and then kicking it out harrison
went for the hammer smart
move buddy with the soft hands and the
touch
all the way from the bahamas
tireless indefatigable
effort at the defensive end by
sacramento barnes just
dogged effort knocked it loose from
jokic to fox
with the nice touch on the pass and then
buddy healed off the miss
oh they earned this one mark oh they did
oh earned it they deserved
a positive fate as sacramento
wins it 124 to 122
they end an odious
six-game losing streak in the mile high
city nobody's going to catch buddy
tonight all you're going to see is his
shoe bottoms folks
he is gone and so are the nuggets
vanquished by sacramento